hello and welcome to the section on
unsupervised learning
so this is really a sudden
shift in topic we're moving on to a
new section within the class
so far everything we've talked about in
the class has been
supervised learning and now we're going
to start talking about unsupervised
learning
and the idea in supervised learning is
that we have pairs of records u
and v and we want to learn
a model which predicts v
given you and the
it's called supervised learning because
the the vi's
are giving us information
about what the right answer is in
particular cases corresponding to the
uis
and this is supervising is the idea the
learning of the model
in unsupervised learning it's different
we only have
records u and our
goal is to build a model of
the use and so we'd like to be able to
do things such as reveal
the structure of the set of possible use
we'd like to be able to deal with
missing entries in the use and figure
out what they are
that's called imputation we'd like to be
able to detect anomalies
unusual cases which we've not seen
before
and the idea of revealing structure or
detecting anomalies are both
kind of vague at this point and we'll
make them a little bit more precise
and imputing missing entries well we'll
see exactly how to do that
so just as before we work with embedded
data we take our data u
and we embed it into a feature vector x
x is phi of u and x is some vector that
lives in our
d and then we build our data model
for the vectors x and when we need to we
unembed
to go back to the raw vector u
so from now on in this section we're
going to work
with feature vectors x so i have
embedded data set x1 so xn each of these
is a vector in our d
now the way we construct a model
for this data set
is via a loss function
we'd like to have something which
characterizes
the elements of the data set which tells
us what elements of the data set
look like or should look like and
i'm going to do this with a loss
function which we could also call in
this case an implausibility function
it's a function on rd which is our space
of possible x's
real valued and it tells us how
implausible x
is as a data point so if l of x is small
then x looks like our data it's typical
and if l of x is large then x does not
look like the data
now the model might be probabilistic so
x
might correspond to a probability
distribution or a probability density
p of x and then we would take l of x's
to be
the negative log of p of x which is the
negative log
probability density we might think of
that as the negative log
likelihood of x
other names for l x we might talk about
surprise or perplexity
um an l is often parametrized by a
vector or
theta it might be a matrix theta
and so we'll put a subscript theta on
l l sub theta of x
let's look at the simplest example
suppose
um our data model is x is near
a fixed vector theta
so the model here is parameterized by
the vector theta
and we're going to try and learn that
from the data
you might have implausibility functions
associated with this
for example you might have the square
loss
which would be the sum of the squares of
the two norm
of x minus theta sorry
that's correct or the one norm of x
minus theta
which is the sum of the absolute values
of x i minus theta i
a different data model is the k-means
data model
here the idea is is that rather than
just having
one ideal point one representative we
have k of them
theta one to c to k all vectors in rd
and we believe that our data
is close to one of these representatives
now we measure how implausible
data point x is by saying what's the
distance
between x and the closest representative
which is just the minimum from is one to
k of the norm
of x minus theta i squared if it's the
distance squared that we're using as our
distance measure
we might equally well use a a one norm
or a different norm normally for k means
k means specifically means
the squared distance
squared two norm distance
then the model is parameterized by these
uh k d dimensional vectors which we can
equally well view as a d
by k matrix which will call theta
whose columns are theta 1 through c
decay
now it's worth looking at what the role
of the loss function is in supervised
versus unsupervised learning in
supervised learning the loss function is
used to choose a particular
predictor from a family of predictors
parameterized by theta
and once we've chosen the predictor we
no longer really care about the loss
function
the predictor itself is our model
of how x and y are related
in unsupervised learning the the loss
function
plays a slightly different role because
it characterizes what the data looks
like
um but the loss function actually is the
data model
getting getting the loss function that's
that's the primary goal
of unsupervised learning
so using this loss function enables us
to build for example an anomaly detector
that's a particular way of using a data
model in order to
identify anomalies suspicious feature
vectors
feature vectors that aren't consistent
with the other feature vectors that
we've seen
for example the common application is
say network traffic monitoring we might
have feature vectors that includes
statistics of the size and
distribution of packets and
what we do is we fit our data model we
have a loss function l
parameterized by cedar we fit that by
choosing the theta
and then we'll say that if we look at
all of our data
x1 through xn we can look at the
corresponding distribution of the loss
function
and we can say let's find the percentile
value
say the 99th percentile value of that
loss function
so that 99 of the values that we've
observed
of l of x are less than or equal to t
and then when we're getting new data
coming in
as we're watching the network if we
every time we get an x we evaluate
the loss function on it we are flagged
as anomalous
if the loss function is greater than our
threshold t
it's greater than that 99 percentile
value
um and this is a
anomaly detector
we can also use our data model to impute
missing entries so we'll suppose that x
has some
entries missing we might label them with
question marks or n a
or n a n for not available or for not a
number
within the data set and
uh we'd like to
fill in those missing data entries
so uh
for any given vector x we've got
a subset of the numbers one through d
which is the set of known entries
we'll call that set script k for that
data element
x and um
uh we're going to replace
x with x hat and
x hat is going to be such that well
its value on the known entries on if i
is one of the known
is one of the known entries then we'll
have x hat i equal to x i
now if i is not one of the known entries
well then we're going to have to fill it
in and we're going to have x
hat eyes question mark that we're going
to have to replace
so on the slide here we have an example
where
x here has a dimension
four and k is one three which means we
know
the first and the third entry
of x and our job is going to be
to fill in these unknown entries
here we fill them in with minus 1.5
and 3.4 and this quantity on the right
is x hat
and the in the first and the third entry
of x hat
are forced to be equal to the first and
the third entries of x because we know
the first and the third entries but our
job is to fill in the others
and of course k is might be different
for each of our different
data records so for each i we might have
a different
k
so an example of this is for say a
recommendation system
um the
features here are different
movies and
the examples are customer
ratings so we will have d different
movies
and n different customers and each
customer
has filled in ratings for some of the
movies
so if d could be very large if we look
at the netflix catalog there may be many
thousands of different possible movies
and so x say is a vector in r of ten
thousand
but for each particular customer
you may have only watched a few of the
movies and so most of the entries will
be question marks
and then some other entries will be
faded
maybe they'll be rated on a likert scale
from one to five
and then our job is to impute
the entries the missing entries and that
tells us
what rating the customer would give if
they
rated that particular movie
and then we're going to use this
information to actually make a
recommendation
we will look for each customer at
the imputed values and find um
those imputed values which are large so
movies that they
would have rated large if only they
rated it and we'll send a recommendation
to them saying
you might like this movie
and this is exactly um
what is called the netflix challenge
where
a few years ago now there was a prize
offered by netflix
for just people to build
a recommendation system uh which could
impute
ratings in this way
another application would be to fill in
missing features
for supervised learning so you're trying
to do supervised learning you want to do
classification
regression and
your exes have some missing features
and so far what we've done is removed
records that have
feet missing features all of the methods
we've seen so far have required us
to have every data record i
have an xi which is complete it can't
have any question marks or
nas in there
and sometimes you do lose a substantial
fraction of the data
so so
for example some of the data sets we
looked at earlier for example we looked
at an australian
weather data set we lost a substantial
fraction of the data by eliminating
those those
records which were just missing one
element
and so an alternative approach would be
to use into imputation
to fill in the missing feature entries
and then use the filled in data set to
do supervised learning
another thing you can use imputation for
is to detect enormous entries
so here we're not trying to detect
anomalous records
but in almost entries so particular
components of
a particular x so what do we do well for
each i
we pretend that
the x i com the i component of x
is question mark is unknown and we
impute
to find x hat of i we impute based on
all the other entries of x
and if x i and x hat i are very
different well then we'll flag x
i as anomalous in the case of our movies
example we've identified movies which we
would expect
based on all the other movies that the
person has rated
that they would not have liked but
actually they gave it a high rating
or vice versa
um now the distinction between
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning is not
so great in particular
one can view supervised learning as a
special case
of imputation at least one can formulate
supervised learning as a special case of
imputation
so suppose we want to predict y based on
x
well we have this training data of x 1
to x n y 1 to y n
we'll construct a new set of records
consisting of d plus m dimensional
vectors x tilde
each x tilde is simply x stacked up on
top of y
um now we build a data model for x
tilde using this training data
and then we impute the last m entries
of x tilde and it so happens that
every record is missing the last
m entries of x tilde
now in order to use a data model to
perform imputation we
look at our vector x
i and we say well we don't know
what some of the entries are but we know
what the other entries are
so the entries that we don't know we're
going to choose
by picking them such that the
loss function l is minimum
so specifically we say well i've got a
loss function it's a function of an x
i'm going to fix the components that i
know and i'm going to allow myself to
vary the components that i don't know
and we minimize the implausibility
which is just the loss function
so this is a very natural thing to do
and it turns out that it works
very well
so here's here's an example so here we
have a constant
data model and
so we have a bunch of data points here
shown in
red and we have
our theta which is the
parameter that specifies the model our
model says
that the
we expect all of the data to be close
to theta in other words we have a loss
function
which is the norm of x minus theta
squared
first thing we do is we pick the theta
given the data and that gives us that
the theta
is the mean of those data points
the second thing we do is we say well
we've got a theta
and now we're going to find uh
solve an imputation problem and in our
imputation problem
we are given an
x with a missing entry so
we know x it has
two components um the first one is
unknown
and the second one is 2.8 and that means
that the true x is somewhere along this
line
somewhere along the line of vectors
x which have second component equal to
2.8
we get to pick x1 and the way we're
going to do that
is by minimizing the loss function over
x1 subject to the constraint that x2
is 2.8
and now that gives us
this point right here we get to move
along this line
along that line to get as close as
possible as we can
to theta theta being right there
and that turns out to be x hat one is
0.79
if we have a k means data model well
here we have an
x with some unknown entries now the last
function
is the minimum over i
of the norm of x minus theta i squared
so in other words you look over all of
your k different theta vectors
okay different archetypes pick the one
that's closest to x
and look at the distance between x and
that closest archetype
squared and that gives you the loss
now we've got an x that has some missing
entries
and so when we do this well some of the
entries are fixed we can't do anything
about those
and the other entries we get to minimize
the loss function with respect to so
the first thing we do is we say well
let's find the nearest
representative theta j to x
but we can only use the known entries
and that means that
instead of looking at the two norm we
have to look at
the sum over all of the known entries
the i's in k and look at the
that sum of x i minus
the i component of theta j squared
that is the
loss function here
evaluated let's include the minimum
evaluated where we've allowed the
components that we don't know
to be free when we allow the components
that we don't know to be free
will they gravitate to be such that
x sub i is equal to the i component of
theta j
because that minimizes that loss
and so we end up with a lot with a loss
that has
only these terms left in it
so just to be explicit about that the
minimum over i
of the norm of x minus
theta i norm squared
that's our l of x
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to minimize
l of x subject to
the constraint that x
x hat x hat i is equal
to x i for i in the known set
and if i take the minimum
of this l of x i end up
with minimizing over
x hat the minimum over i
of the norm of x hat minus
theta i guess i've used i twice
let's use what j for one of them
let's replace that one with the j
uh x minimum over j
minus theta j norm squared
and this minimum on the outside
is a minimum with respect to the unknown
components
minimize with respect
to unknown
components
of x hat
and if we minimize with respect to the
unknown components of x hat
this quantity well
one thing i can do is swap the order
of the minimizations and that becomes
the minimum
over j the minimum over the
unknowns
of the norm of x hat minus theta j
and this well if i'm if i'm allowed to
choose the unknown components
of x hat to minimize that quantity what
am i going to do
i'm going to make the unknown components
equal to the corresponding components of
theta j
and that leaves me with this
part of the cost function here equal
to just this
so that that tells us how to
pick the
uh
the representative corresponding
to a particular x tells us how to pick j
and then what we want to do is we want
to pick
the unknown components well we already
know what they are
they have to be equal such they have to
be such that x hat i
is equal to the ice component of c to j
so for the unknown entries what we do is
we
guess the entries of the closest
representative
so we have a data model and just like in
supervised learning we need to be able
to validate
that our data model is actually good
and our reputation method is actually
good and we do this
in the following way we split the data
into a training set
and a test set we use the training set
to
to the data model and then
what we do is we look at the test set
and
we mask out some of the entries in the
test set we pretend they're unknown
and we impute those entries and then
look at the average
error of the imputed
values so the rmse
for example and that validates that our
imputation method is working correctly
and we would typically pick the training
and the test
split randomly or by k-fold validation
that would be fine
and then we would in order to do the
masking we would typically
mask randomly mask random entries within
the test set
so how do we fit a data model
we have x1 to xn
and let's suppose we have no missing
entries
and we have a parametrized
implausibility function
l theta of x how do we choose the
parameter theta
well we minimize the empirical risk
the average implausibility that's one on
n times the sum from is one to n
of l theta of x i
we choose theta to minimize this
and we may have some constraints on
theta sometimes
the allowed thetas are limited in some
way
and then we choose the parameter theta
so that the observed
data is the least implausible
let's look at the simplest case the sum
of squares loss
so the loss function is l theta of x is
the norm of x minus theta squared the
empirical loss
is the average of that quantity
and we've seen this before when we were
looking at the constant predictor
problem with the square loss
that the best choice of theta
the minimizing choice of theta is the
mean of the data vectors
if we have the
absolute loss some absolute loss well
again
this is a exactly like the constant
predictor case
here in the unsupervised case we will
have a loss function
which is the norm of x minus theta the
one norm is the sum of the absolute
values
of the components of x minus theta
and we look at the empirical loss and
the optimal theta
is the median of the data vectors x1 to
xn
and what this means is the element-wise
median
of the data vectors
then the k-means model
it goes like this the implausibility
function
or the loss function is the the
norm squared of the distance
between x and the closest
archetype theta j
and so our parameter is a d by k matrix
equivalently it's simply k d dimensional
vectors
theta 1 through c decay
now the empirical loss is therefore
the uh
average of that over all of the data
points
so it's 1 on n the sum from i is 1 to n
and then for each i we have to find the
closest
archetype theta j and look at the
distance between
x i and theta j and of course which
closest archetype that is depends on
which data point you have this is the
called the k-means objective function
and we use an algorithm called the
k-means algorithm
to minimize this
so this is one of the cases where we
have a specific problem
which is the k-means optimization
problem we've discussed
and the algorithm has the same name
which is a little confusing because
one could use different algorithms to
solve the same problem
so but the most commonly used algorithm
is called the k-means
algorithm and the way it works is that
for any given choice of these
k vectors theta ones with c decay
well i've got these k vectors and then
i've got a bunch of data points
and each data point its contribution to
the loss
is the distance to its closest
archetype and so we can say let's assign
to each data point a corresponding
archetype
the archetype which is the closest to
that data point
and we're going to label that assignment
with a vector c
in rn and the idea is that ci
is a number between 1 and k
which tells us which of the thetas has
been assigned
to that data point in other words which
of the thetas is the closest to that
data point
and then this loss function which is
the empirical risk is 1 on n the sum
from i is 1 to n
of the distance squared between x
i and its closest archetype
well that's explicitly one on n times
the sum from i is one to n
of this quantity
x i minus theta c
i because c i is the assignment
now what we want to do is we want to
choose both
c and the thetas
so we have to choose the assignment and
choose the corresponding thetas
once we've chosen the thetas the
assignment's easy
right the assignment is that we assign
to each to the ith data point the
closest archetype
so we find over j the minimum
of x i minus theta j the norm of x
i minus theta j squared and that's what
c i is is
which of the j's minimizes that quantity
how do we minimize the thetas
well we can
minimize this quantity
once we fixed the ci's so first of all
we'll do the assignment we'll find the
best ci's
and then minimizing the thetas is
straightforward over the thetas is
straightforward
because each of these
this quantity here splits up into k
different terms one for those
data points assigned to theta one
another for the data points assigned to
theta two and so on
and so it becomes
well it becomes this becomes
one on n times the sum over all
i such that c i is one
of the norm of x i minus theta one
squared plus
1 on n times the sum over all i
such that c i is 2 of the norm
of x i minus theta 2
squared and so on up to k
and each one of those we would like to
minimize that sum
over theta one through c to k and so to
find the minimum
over theta one we minimize this over c
to 1
and minimizing that over c to 1 simply
tells us to set theta 1
to be the mean of the corresponding x
i's
to minimize this over theta 2
we set theta 2 to be the mean of the
corresponding
x i's in other words all of the x i's
which have been assigned
to category 2
and so on
once we do that well then we've got new
theta i's and that means that the
assignment might change
and so we reassign we go
we we go through and once again
pick the c's that that
assign each x
i to the closest theta j
that's a new assignment and that means
that the thetas are going to change and
so we go through and we
update all the thetas to be the
corresponding means
of their assigned data points and we
alternate between these two steps
assign data points
to archetypes then
adjust the archetypes to be the mean of
their assigned data points
then assign data points to archetypes
and so on
and this is a heuristic for
approximately minimizing
this empirical risk
here's an example so we start out
with uh some
guesses for theta and we might
initialize those completely randomly
that would be very common
so here there are three guesses
this is say theta 1
theta 2 and theta 3.
and now given those
guesses for the thetas we can make
assignments
all of the points for which which are
closest
to theta one than any of the other
thetas
are being colored in red the points that
are closest to theta two of colored blue
and the points that are closest to theta
3 are colored green remember we don't
have any colors associated with our data
our data is just points but once we've
picked thetas
we can label
the data points and those labels are the
ci's
so all of these red points are those
points for which
ci is one the blue points are
points which ci is two and the green
points are points which
ci is 3. so now we've got an assignment
we've picked the c's by painting
the points in their appropriate colors
now we can see that
well these thetas don't minimize
the empirical risk with those
assignments
because i can make the empirical risk
smaller by moving
this theta to the mean of all of these
data points which is somewhere here
and i can move this theta to the mean of
its assigned data points
there and this one doesn't move very
much maybe it moves a little bit
in this direction say
so i move them and this is where they
end up
and now that i've moved them i can
reassign each data point to its closest
archetype
that changes their colors so now i've
got the same data points but i've
recolored them
according to their closest archetype so
now these are the red ones here
these are the blue ones and these the
green ones
and we can see that some data points
have changed from red to blue and some
have changed from blue to red
none of the green ones have changed
and so now i've reassigned data points
my
archetypes are no longer in the best
possible place
i adjust my archetypes to be
the mean of their corresponding data
points
so this one's going to move up a bit
this one's going to move down a bit
and i keep going until i converge
alternating between assigning colors and
taking the means
and here's the sort of convergence you
see this is converged very quickly
after four iterations we've completely
converged
and uh and notice that this converges
perfectly in the sense that
once we've uh once we're not
changing the assignments c
anymore well then the theaters don't
change either
and so this isn't a uh
this reaches a point where the theaters
are
stuck and no longer move at all
here we can look at the
both the training loss and the test loss
and the imputation error
and so you can see here in blue there's
the training loss
in green you can see the test loss
follows pretty closely
and then the red is the imputation error
and this tells and this is as a function
of k
the number the parameter which is the
number of archetypes we're choosing
and so how do we choose this well this
suggests
that maybe we should pick a k
somewhere around four or five
or maybe even three so i guess this is
one this is two three so we should pick
a k that's three
which is quite reasonable if we look at
our data set
our data set really does split naturally
into three clusters
and our algorithm has found that
and then we can validate by removing
either u1 or u2 from each record in the
test set
and computing the rmse
you